[Music]
I've been doing this talk-show thing for
a long time almost 20 years and
sometimes I think back on all the
impressions I've heard people do and
I've actually had people asked me who's
the best and I will say that this
gentleman right here does the best
Christopher Walken that impression
that's an impression a lot of people do
but yours is lightyears ahead of
everybody else first of all that's
poppycock I don't know why you would say
such a thing
in front of everyone as well where do we
go from here you have to kind of lose
yourself in it you you have to remember
that all this he clearly has you've got
to lean into it yeah I mean I I've been
doing impersonations in my whole
stand-up career which is forever he's
the first one that once I start doing
him I can't really stop yeah funny for
you
I mean I'll walk around the house
sometimes for a couple of hours speaking
only as Christopher Walken not realizing
I'm doing it until the cat passes out
from fear that's so you're just by
yourself not even an audience no I'm
what are you saying I'll start the day
open the fridge in the morning like
anyone does and then it just happens
oh my we're out of soy milk tragic news
for the lactose intolerant I wasn't
planning a trip to the market today but
clearly a drive to Trader Joe's is in my
future yeah you go anyway you've done a
pot yet you did a podcast where you
interview your friends as Christopher
Walken it's really easy
you're just thumb you can talk about
anything you got to keep in mind calling
all of his thoughts are completely
disconnected with that in mind
ask me anything I'll show you how it
works okay how did you like being in
wedding crashes I don't if you know this
but you can actually check in to Kim
Kardashian's ass on Foursquare I was the
mayor for a week
[Laughter]